I've been receiving this question a lot
in the last few years not just in the
comments but also on other social media
it surprised me because I thought this
had been covered quite thoroughly in the
past but then I realized that I've been
playing these games for like seven and a
half years and making content on it for
the last five or six years obsessing
over it daily and there are obviously a
lot of people have only just come in
later on
so in this video I'd like to put
together a quick timeline on what
happened to the military in the days
following the outbreak
[Music]
before I jump into the story I just want
to clarify a few things those not
familiar with us especially those not
from the United States there seems to be
a little bit of confusion around some of
these terms so I'm just going to quickly
clear these up
military is a word used to refer to the
entire Armed Forces
the word Army is just one subset of many
branches within the military
within the US the other arms of the
military include the Navy Coast Guard
Marines Air Force and space force
a person who is on active duty is in the
military full time they work for the
military full-time may live on a
military base and can be deployed at any
time
persons in the reserve or National Guard
are not full-time active duty military
personnel although they can be deployed
at any time should the need arise
the Posse commentators act as a United
States federal law which limits the
power of the federal government in the
use of federal military personnel to
enforce domestic policies within the
United States
it bars federal troops from
participating in civilian law
enforcement except when expressly
authorized by law
the ACT applies to the Army Air Force
Navy Marine Corps and space force
the ACT does not prevent the National
Guard and the state Authority from
acting in a law enforcement capacity
within its home or state or in an
adjacent state if invited by that
State's governor
the United States Coast Guard is also
not covered by the ACT primarily because
although it is an armed service it also
has a maritime law enforcement mission
martial law in the United States refers
to times in which a city region State or
the whole United States is placed under
the control of a military body
on a national level both the U.S
president and the U.S Congress have
power within certain constraints to
declare martial law
some of what I've talked about here is
actually more complicated than this but
for the nature of this video and the
division story this is more than enough
for understanding their purpose
banknotes coded with variola Chimera a
highly contagious smallpox strain now
called the green poison are circulated
in New York City
within days the emergence of disease
symptoms Sparks are devastating
contagion that sweeps through the city
overwhelming medical facilities
in response the federal government's
Disease Control Division and other
authorities swiftly declare a state of
emergency
however the rapid spread of the disease
renders containment efforts futile
the National Guard is called upon
leading to a complete lockdown of New
York City roads are blocked public
transport is suspended and Crosstown
travel is prohibited
the populace is mandated to take shelter
in their homes while all businesses
shutter their doors
as Dawn breaks on the following day New
Yorkers wake up to a hauntingly quiet
City
foreign
initiates a large-scale vaccination
campaign utilizing available stockpiles
to combat the Contagion
initially targeting First Responders in
key areas of transmission the focus soon
expands to inoculating the general
public at various locations like clinics
workplaces and parking lots
amidst the Eerie calm a semblance of
normalcy returns it stores cautiously
reopen during Limited hours and people
are allowed on the streets within strict
curfew regulations
Sarah establishes Field clinics across
the city providing suppliers antiviral
medications and protective gear to the
population
additionally a centralized Mass
treatments facility for severe smallpox
cases is set up within a sealdoth sixth
Zone in Midtown Manhattan surrounded by
a reinforced perimeter wall
sadly within a matter of days two Grim
realities emerge
firstly it becomes evident that the
existing smallpox vaccine is ineffective
against the new virus strain
secondly the relaxation of movement
restrictions inadvertently accelerates
the spread of the disease leading to
thousands of new cases in a devastating
way to fatalities sweeping across the
city
the outbreak has officially declared a
global pandemic by the World Health
Organization prompting the president to
invoke Nationwide martial law
in New York dwindling supplies of food
and Necessities lead to the emergence of
black markets and Smugglers seeking to
exploit the situation
civil unrest becomes apparent as losers
defied curfews posing threats to
hospitals in stores
fear in energy infect the city with
panicked New Yorkers attempting to flee
and clashing with troops and forcing
quarantine lines
streets descend into lawlessness
outnumbered and overwhelmed by mob
violence security teams reluctantly
withdraw from chaotic neighborhoods
surviving police and military units
unite to form the Joint Task Force
the jtf informs a complete lockdown of
all five boroughs tightly controlling
the movement between them
while this facilitates Safety Management
on a city-wide scale that intensifies
the challenges faced by the teams
operating in Manhattan the most densely
populated and severely affected burrow
the pandemic spreads to Washington DC
triggering a rapid escalation of civil
unrest fueled by the sensationalized
media coverage of the chaos in New York
City
Public Services break down within 72
hours
so what actually happened to the
military
it was during and following these events
that International Trade shuts down
creating a food and security crisis as
the pandemic spreads around the globe
suffering from a broken chain of command
mass desertions and death due to the
virus and attrition through fighting to
maintain order the United States
military is thrown into crisis
is the civil unrest and Chaos escalated
following the green poison attack
decisions from military law enforcement
and other first responder units became
common
the shocking Street Cemetery combined
with concern for loved ones motivated
many deserters to evacuate
the real world event that happened
recently showed us how vulnerable the
military really is to biological attacks
enlisted single soldiers live in tight
housing and tend to congregate together
when they have free time it was during
this time that there was a lot of free
time and soldiers ended up spreading the
disease quickly through the ranks
summing up the chain of command has
collapsed ranks were ravaged by the
dollar flew due to the close-quartered
living situations those who were able to
get back home to a systemistically after
martial law was invoked continued to get
thinned out due to the severity of the
chaos dwindling support numbers and
concern for loved ones leading to Mass
desertions
those who are still active have for the
most part joined with the jtf
I believe there are still pockets of
military units that were cut off
overseas but also within the US itself I
imagined that there are a number of
smaller towns that may not have a jtf
presence at all so the soldiers in these
areas may be holding things down on
their own
however I still think most who are able
to fight will be with the jtf if
anything just to take advantage of the
infrastructure they've been able to put
in place
and then of course there are a number of
these jtf who had later become true Sons
but I think we all have a pretty good
idea of how the story plays out
I think we need to remember that the
premise behind the division is fairly
straightforward when all other measures
have failed they are the last line of
defense
in the world of the division the
military has been decimated and is now
no more than perhaps a few isolated
units with little to no leadership
keeping them connected to each other
with the rest of them now deeply
ingrained into the jtf
[Music]
I actually quite enjoyed the excuse to
go back so many years to revisit scripts
and recordings I often find myself
coming across pieces of information that
I hadn't noticed the first couple of
times or in some cases didn't seem all
that significant at the time
so people who are maybe a little newer
to the franchise did this help you with
understanding what happened to the
military and did you have anything else
from around this time that I could
possibly round up for you
let me know in the comments or Twitter
or Instagram I may not always respond
but I read every single one of them
anyway thank you very much for watching
I hope you've enjoyed this video and
I'll catch you in the next one extremist
malice extreme remedial
hahaha
[Applause]
[Music]